l'hebdo politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'hebdo
politique votre rendez vous de dimanche
soir sur radio sensations en association
avec tv 78 épisodes 217 mon invité ce
soir le président du mouvement de la
ruralité en ile de france yannick
villardier
les politiques
ni villardier bonsoir bonsoir alors vous
êtes le président du mouvement de la
ruralité en ile de france et conseiller
municipal du coudray montceaux en
essonne il y a cinq ans vous vous étiez
présenté aux élections législatives dans
la 2e circonscription de l'essonne vous
étiez soutenu à l'époque par le parti de
nicolas dupont aignan debout la france
et vous vous êtes présenté en 2020 aux
élections municipales de votre ville le
coudray-montceaux dans l'essonne vous
meniez alors une liste d'union sans
étiquette et avait récolté 44 30 % des
voix face à aurélie gros la maire
actuelle de votre commune vous avez été
nommé en 2021 président du mouvement de
la ruralité en ile de france dans la
région est la plus urbaine du pays elle
compte plus de 12 millions d'habitants
est-ce que cela rend l'ile-de-france
particulière pour un mouvement tel que
le vôtre les enjeux sont ils différents
quel est le poids de la ruralité dans
une telle région vous avez raison oui
c'est forcément différent d'un d'une
région rurale comme je sais pas moi le
sud-ouest où d'autres régions comme ça
mais pour autant la moitié de
de l'île de france et en zone agricole
en zone rurale et finalement on retrouve
des problématiques qui sont quasiment
similaires des rayons dit de province
notamment par exemple les problèmes de
de service
deux collectivités que ce soit
pôle emploi de ce soit la poste que ce
soit là trésor public etc on retrouve
aussi les mêmes problématiques pour le
transport voire même parfois plus en ile
de france on sait que c'est une vraie
vraie problématique de cette région et
puis les problématiques liées aux
agriculteurs enfin etc etc on sait c'est
vrai que c'est c'est moins flagrant
mais mais effectivement c'est c'est une
réalité de cette région aussi depuis la
fin de l'année dernière vous est donc
devenu le président du moment réalité en
ile de france quels sont les objectifs
et les défis que vous est fixé au cours
de cette mission alors en fait je
j'avais cette fonction pendant de très
nombreuses années comme c'était à
l'époque cpnt chasse pêche nature et
tradition que je l'avais quittée pour
diverses raisons notamment points de
désaccord avec l'ancien président
et puis et puis il ya deux ans trois ans
de ça il des piges à l'on m'a fait cette
proposition de revenir
et que j'ai accepté effectivement c'est
ma famille politique d'origine quoi j'ai
fait pratiquement toute ma vie politique
dans ce mouvement
donc j'ai accepté alors l'objectif
c'était de restructurer parce qu'en fait
la partie elle est maire sur la région
ile de france avait été un peu délaissé
ces dernières années donc là l'idée
c'était de restructurer donc là on a
désigné des nouveaux présidents des
différents départements on couvre pas
encore toute l'ile-de-france et la
seine-et-marne les yvelines alors est ce
que c'est ça seine-et-marne yvelines
essonne paris et valdoie sont en cours
malgré tout il ya une base militante
puisque j'ai eu les fichiers il ya
quelques mois j'étais très étonné de
voir qu'il y avait beaucoup d'adhérents
donc c'est plutôt plutôt un côté positif
et puis l'un des objectifs ça va être
les législatives clairement
on s'est fixé pour objectif de présenter
un maximum de candidates et de candidats
alors c'est pas encore tranché il ya
encore des négociations cours il faut
encore qu'on vérifie certaines
candidatures il ya des endroits où on a
peut-être intérêt à aller d'autres pas
il faut peut-être qu'on aille sur
certaines circonscriptions comme celle
de villa ni ou d'autres pour aller jouer
un petit peu les troublions
donc voilà ça se fasse faire d'ici le
mois de mai mais mais j'ai bon espoir
parce qu on a pas mal de candidature et
puis
voilà donc une vraie restructuration du
mouvement
ça c'est vraiment l'objectif principal
avec les législatives alors ce mouvement
de la ruralité donc pour va faire un
petit peu un historique d'un parti
politique français dont qui a été créée
en 1989 c'est ça et anciennement appelée
donc comme vous l'avez dit chasse pêche
nature et traditions cnpt en 2019 il a
été renommé mouvement de la ruralité le
siège du parti est lui situé à à pau
dans les pyrénées-atlantiques alors ça
les différencier un petit peu des autres
partis posent ici c'est ça quelles sont
les principales valeurs de ce mouvement
alors à la base c c'est un mouvement qui
est né en réaction aux directives
européennes contre la chasse donc cécile
d'ailleurs je suis arrivé à ce moment là
dans ce mouvement
mais assez rapidement en fait les
personnes qui ont créé ce mouvement sont
en du compte que on pouvait pas
seulement défendre la chasse ça se
voulait être un parti de défense de la
chasse en fait c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
attirait les médias à l'époque partie de
la chasse c'était le parti de la chose
défendre des chasses on nous disait
pourquoi pas défendre les footballeurs
ou voilà est assez rapidement en fait
les gens qui ont composé ce mouvement
dans lesquels ont retrouvé des élus des
élus qui étaient implantés dans leur
territoire se sont rendus compte qu'en
fait la chasse n'était qu'en fait à une
image en fait de ce qui se passe dans le
monde rural est en fait
pour eux en fait le la chasse n'était
qu'un élément parmi d'autres problèmes à
venir qui était notamment dû à l'europe
donc à cette époque là on était vraiment
anti européen et depuis notre mentalité
forcément évolué et est donc assez
rapidement ils se sont inscrits dans une
logique de défense du monde rural dans
sa globalité mais il y avait quand même
à cpnt une majorité de chasseurs et
cette image me collait à la peau et on
avait du mal à faire passer le message
que l'on défende et d'autres choses même
si
cpnt y avait des agriculteurs il y avait
il des gens que je sais pas non plus de
même qu on nous a souvent associé à la
droite voire l'extrême droite alors que
cpnt était composé à moitié de jambe
gauche donc si c'était voilà et et donc
lorsque eddy puyjalon a pris la
présidence du mouvement
il a d'abord imaginé faire évoluer le
mouvement sur sur autre chose et après
plusieurs débats il s'est avéré qu'il
fallait changer le nom et puis il
fallait ouvrir véritablement de manière
quasi officiel même si ça se faisait
naturellement à des personnes qui
n'étaient pas chasseur
et c'est comme ça que le mouvement et
les maires et n'est donc c'est assez
vrai que c'est le jeune mouvement qui
vient dans la continuité de cpnt mais
qui aujourd'hui véritablement
le bureau national ou conseil national
sont composés je dirais aux trois quarts
de personnes qui chassent pas
votre mouvement se veut indépendant il
de droite ni de gauche pourtant dans les
faits on a plutôt tendance en enfin
envie de vous placer à droite et surtout
en totale opposition avec europe
ecologie les verts alors pourquoi ce
qu'il ya une telle animosité entre les
deux mouvements c'est finalement c'est
assez simple si que naturellement la
droite défend nos valeurs et la gauche
les combats ça je vais le résumer comme
ça c'est simpliste mais mais c'est ça
c'est à dire qu'en fait peut-être qu'à
20 ou 30 ans n'aurait pu s'entendre
parce que moi j'ai pour habitude de dire
que le monde rural il est ni de droite
ni de gauche enfin on défend des idées
on défend d opinion mais mais mais c'est
pas le cas d'europe écologie les verts
c'est pas le cas de la france insoumise
ce qui est d'ailleurs ridicule parce que
c'est des gens sont menées en off lorsqu
on est entre nous on se rend compte et
qu'on discute souvent on se rejoint sur
plein de dossiers sur plein d'idées mais
mais j'ai envie de dire que le la classe
politique a voulu politiser le débat est
effectivement de fait on est plutôt à
droite forcément est plutôt à gauche on
le voit parce qu'en fait ils défendent
les mêmes idées bon c'est
c'est comme ça c'est
ça a toujours été europe ecologie les
verts défend l'idée qu'il faut qu'il
faut interdire la chasse par exemple et
nous forcément ça faisait bon de même
que depuis plus de vingt ans on disait
aux pêcheurs attention attention vous
verrez ça va finir par vous tomber
dessus et puis on voit bien depuis trois
quatre cinq ans entre d'un côté la
france insoumise de l'opr de l'autre
europe ecologie les verts ou maintenant
le parti animalistes on voit qu'il ya
quand même quelque chose qui va vers une
interdiction de tous et donc ça c'est
ben ouais c'est insupportable parce que
ça signifie que la ruralité l'écologie
sont très combative n'ont justement pas
pour moi qui me suis engagé dans des
associations dans d'autres combats dans
des représentants de commissions en
préfecture etc on voit que les
écologistes peuvent travailler avec les
chasseurs et vice versa mais sur le
terrain ce soir terrain on arrive à se
retrouver mais c'est la base qui se
retrouve c'est pas les politiques et je
pense qu'il ya véritablement une
manipulation de l'opinion une
manipulation des idées à dessein à des
fins politiques tout simplement alors
votre un mouvement de la réalité dénonce
une inégalité du service de l'état entre
les zones rurales et les zones urbaines
alors comment se matérialise au
quotidien cette inégalité ce que je vous
disais par exemple tout à l'heure sur
les services de l'état
où
on va plutôt favorisé la fermeture de
services en zone rurale et on va les
maintenir en zone urbaine parce que en
zone urbaine ça coûte moins cher parce
qu'à une concentration personne
et pourtant on zones rurales forcément
la difficulté elle se fait ressentir je
veux dire un village qui perd sa pose
d'un village qui perd sa trésorerie
publique enfin forcément c'est un
village qui se meurt parce que parce que
les gens ont d'autres perd en
attractivité qui perd notre activité la
jav est l'exemple d'une personne que je
connais quelques habitants lozère bon
c'est pas l'ile-de-france mais c'est la
lozère qui a un type de cancer
particulier qui ne peut se faire soigner
qu'à montpellier donc en cours d'année
elle peut trouver effectivement des
véhicules pour l'âme pour l'emmener
plusieurs heures de route mais l'hiver
impossible donc l'hiver c'est son mari
qui doit prendre une voiture rouler dans
la neige
effectivement il y avait à l'époque
pas très loin de là où elle habite une
grande ville où il y avait un service de
soins ce service a fermé et de fête donc
c'est des exemples concrets c'est
désolant bête et puis à côté il ya
évidemment l'aspect l'aspect financier
c'est à dire qu'on a plutôt tendance à
financer dans les zones urbaines plutôt
que dans les zones rurales mais
néanmoins il faut quand même dire les
choses par exemple en ile de france on à
la région ile de france et beaucoup pour
les zones rurales nous dans l'essonne le
conseil départemental fait beaucoup pour
les zones rurales la seine et marne
c'est pareil mais simplement il ya ce
qu'ils peuvent faire et il ya ce que
l'état ne veut pas faire
chacun s'est complètement mais voilà est
donc quelque part il arrive à compenser
sur certaines choses
mais il ya le discours de l'état au
niveau national et à la réalité du
terrain qui est quand même pas du tout
la même dans le cadre de l'élection
présidentielle donc le mouvement de la
ruralité a émis 30 propositions pour
revitaliser la france rurale et peser
dans le débat politique alors selon vous
la france rurale c'est un tiers des
français qui la vivent au quotidien
selon les chiffres du mouvement elle
doit selon vous devenir une grande cause
une grande cause nationale et vous
voulez la création d'un ministère
spécialement dédié à la ruralité alors
qu'est ce qui justifierait la création
d'un tel poste alors j'ai repris les 30
points effectivement c'est le point
numéro un c'est la création d'un
ministère de la ruralité classés entre
le 2e et 6e rang au protocole avec en
son sein la création d'un secrétariat
d'état aux ressources renouvelables
incorporant la chasse la pêche et la
forêt pourquoi parce que en fait depuis
toujours c'est un staff vieux débat en
fait c'est pas propre à nous
la chasse dépend du ministère de
l'environnement et on a souvent demandé
à être plutôt au ministère de
l'agriculture
mais voilà c'est comme ça c'est établi
ce ministère de l'environnement qu'est
ce que l'on constate sur différents
gouvernements quels qu'ils soient de
droite de gauche ou aujourd'hui la
république en marche c'est qu'on met à
la tête de ces ministères on met à la
tête des anti-chasse c'est idéologique
barbara pompili est une anti chasse
notoire et qu'elle s'en cache pas et
elle fait tout contre la chasse donc est
là elle est ministre de tutelle de
quelque chose qu'elle combat dont
quelque chose c'est pas normal et en
fait donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
on soutient cette idée qui est la nôtre
depuis quinze ou vingt ans reprise
aujourd'hui par emmanuel macron donc qui
normalement s'il est réélu fera fera ce
ministère mais on a demandé aux autres
candidats à l'élection présidentielle de
s'inscrire aussi dans cette logique
parce que parce qu'il nous semble qu'il
faut que ce ministère soit indépendant
et que ce ministère en fête regroupe les
composantes finalement
de ski et or environnement mais de tout
ce qui touche aux utilisateurs de la
nature
cela ne vous a pas échappé on va venir
maintenant au prix de l'énergie leurs
noms ont donc qu'ils sont un niveau le
plus haut jamais atteint une
augmentation qui impacte encore plus les
habitants des zones rurales pas ou peu
de transport en commun plus de distance
entre le domicile et le lieu de travail
on pense souvent que c'est moins cher de
vivre en zone rurale que les prix les
loyers sont moins élevés qu'en ville le
pouvoir d'achat est une grande
préoccupation pour cette élection
présidentielle et quelle est la position
du mouvement de la ruralité sur sur le
sujet ce que vous avez des propositions
les propositions oui elles sont toujours
les mêmes mais mais en fait
effectivement le pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui c'est si oui c'est un sujet
majeur de tous les français finalement
avec ce c7 guerre en ukraine
sûr sûr sûr
le les zones rurales
effectivement on se rend compte que le
pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir d'achat est
un problème parce que prenez certaines
régions où certains départements où les
gens n'arrivent même plus à se loger
prenez la haute savoie par exemple
un local de la peine à trouver un
logement ou alors à des prix exorbitants
c'est le cas dans le var c'est le cas
dans plein d'endroits en france donc
effectivement il faut trouver des
solutions on a en a on a alors c'est
valérie pécresse qui avait repris cette
idée à l'époque de cpnt la présidente de
la région elle devrait qui est un euro
investi en zone urbaine en euros
investis en zone rurale et effectivement
ça fonctionne puisque ça se permet de
mettre en place des plans de sauvegarde
des plans d'investissement dé plan de
réindustrialisation
après après encore une fois on en
revient à l'état si l'état si l'état ne
fait pas
l'effort nécessaire ou ne pas en place
les lois nécessaires ou les décrets on
pourra toujours faire toutes les
propositions que l'on doit elle seront
pas suivis la prime inflation 100 euros
qui ne lanciers palais les zones rurales
et des zones urbaines ce la prime à la
prime inflation
et de cash il ya elle est bonne à
prendre pour tout le monde simplement
elle est déjà consommé avec
l'augmentation convient d'avoir donc bon
voilà lé
ccc une rustine sur une jambe de bois
voilà c'est bien de l'avoir fait mais
c'est pas suffisant aujourd'hui il
faudrait geler les taxes il faudrait
effectivement imposé notamment à total
d'éviter d'augmenter et là effectivement
on s'y retrouvait financièrement le prix
des péages autoroutiers a lui aussi
encore augmenté à 2 % de 2% au 1er
février 2022 alors encore une fois c'est
ceux qui font de longs déplacements qui
sont qui sont pénalisés sont pénalisés
comment est-ce que vous jugez cette
augmentation
est les
ailes et les financières les
capitalistes c'est c'est un moyen de
faire rentrer de l'argent dans les
poches des actionnaires
voilà est-ce que c'est justifié
aujourd'hui je crois pas les autoroutes
sont bien entretenus on n'a pas à se
plaindre on a un réseau routier en
france qui est très bien desservi moi
j'ai du mal à comprendre qu'on vient
d'augmenter les péages sauf à vouloir
faire de l'argent voilà en tout cas
peut-être que c'est justifié j'en sais
rien on n'a pas la réponse à ça en tout
cas c'est pas le moment c'est pas
maintenant qu'il faut faire ça enfin je
veux dire c'est en ce moment que les
français souffrent en souffrent toutes
façons on va tous subir de cette guerre
s'il n'y avait pas eu cette guerre on
sortait de deux années d'une crise
sanitaire qui de toute façon va nous
laisser sur les genoux aussi donc
si c'est pour faire un pour moi c'est
incompréhensible voilà nous avons parlé
du pouvoir d'achat pour les ruraux
maintenant nous allons nous intéresser à
l'énergie le débat est animé en france
notamment sur le nucléaire le nucléaire
a été intégré à la taxonomie verte
européenne cela signifique des fonds
européens pourront soutenir la filière
alors que pense vous quelle est votre
position sur le nucléaire mon la
ruralité soutient la filière oui le
monde en réalité soutient nucléaire
depuis toujours après on n'est pas fermé
aux débats d'aller sur d'autres types
d'énergie
mais le nucléaire oui on l'a toujours
défendu parce que il nous semble à
aujourd'hui en tout cas c'est la seule
énergie effectivement efficace
d'ailleurs encore une fois ça nous
ramène à ce conflit armé et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui si la france peut se
relever de ça en tout cas en termes
d'énergie ça sera par le nucléaire ça
veut bien dire qu'il faut pas le
supprimer maintenant
se dire que peut-être d'ici à 50 ans il
faut passer à autre chose je crois pas
on est tous d'accord pour dire que le
nucléaire ça plus donc voilà si même
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que les
matières radioactives peut-être recyclé
dont justement dans d'autres sources
donc voilà mais effectivement lmr a
toujours défendu le nucléaire alors les
énergies renouvelables sont elles
l'avenir la préfecture de la région ile
de france mène un travail
d'identification des zones favorables à
l'implantation des éoliennes selon le
parisien il y à 37 éoliennes en
ile-de-france qui fournissent
aujourd'hui 0 4% de la consommation
c'est ça de la région en électricité une
part donc très faible vous l'avez
compris l'objectif de la région et lui
de doubler la production d'ici 2030 donc
ça reste encore peu quand même mais
l'accord des communes sera selon elle
primordiale pour pour accueillir donc de
nouveaux parcs éoliens un sujet qui
concerne directement les zones rurales
puis mais vous le savez aussi bien que
moi les éoliennes sont rarement se situe
rarement dans les villes quels sont les
avantages qui font que vous n'y est pas
favorable au sein du mouvement d'art en
réalité le mouvement de la ruralité a
toujours été opposés aux éoliennes
industrielles
au départ parce que
liée aux paysages liés aux nuisances que
cela peut apporter
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la pensée a évolué parce que
on a un recul qu'on n'avait pas avant
notamment sur d'autres pays qui sont
plus en avance que la france sur ces
sujets là et qui reviennent justement
sur l'éolien parce que comme on vous
l'avait dit dans votre présentation en
fait l'éolien en règle générale fourni
très peu d'énergie quand ça fonctionne
c'est il faut rappeler ça aussi pour
bien connaître le sujet je peux vous
dire qu'aujourd'hui en france on
construit des parcs éoliens partout où
on peut en construire mais elle ne
fonctionne pas c'est juste parce qu'il
faut rattraper le retard pour pas payer
les amendes à l'europe
après il ya le problème de santé etc le
recul sur le que l'on à aujourd'hui en
france vous avez un lobby pro à lobby
contre le lobby pro forcément essaye de
tout effacer il ya le lobby contre qui
se défend avec ses armes et le recul
qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est un problème de
santé publique
notamment dans les zones où il ya des
exploitations agricoles par exemple de
de deux vaches de vaches laitières et
c'est où ce sont des animaux qui
développent des maladies qui meurent de
façon anormale etc ce recul on là il est
encore un peu jeune commence à y avoir
des études de fait des dossiers
notamment par des scientifiques ou des
laboratoires indépendants et c'est la
raison pour laquelle on dit qu'il est
urgent d'attendre ça fait souvent rire
le film et il est urgent d'attendre
parce qu'il ya peut-être d'autres
sources d'énergie renouvelables comme
les panneaux photovoltaïques mais que
pour lesquels on demande qu'il soit
installé en zone urbaine
au lieu de faire des grands parcs
éoliens et derrière parce que ça génère
des pollutions parce qu'après il faut
les recycler on sait que c'est compliqué
bon voilà tout un processus qui fait que
en l'état actuel des choses on demande à
l'état de d'attendre de patienter de
réfléchir d'étudier les dossiers bon
maintenant effectivement l'état est
censée construire des parcs éoliens
imposées par l'europe
alors du côté des institutions
politiques pour finir donc cette
émission et sur vos propositions vous
souhaité instaurer une dose de
proportionnelle dans chaque élection de
plus de mille électeurs et vous
souhaitez la proportionnelle intégrale
pour les élections régionales alors
selon vous le système actuel n'est pas
assez représentatifs le système est pas
représentatif le meilleur exemple c'est
celui qui dit puijalon donne
régulièrement aux dernières élections
régionales dans le sud-ouest où le
mouvement de la ruralité est arrivé
devant certains partis traditionnels
dans certains départements voire est
arrivé je crois au niveau au niveau
régional en troisième position 4e je
sais plus
réalité au conseil régional de sièges
aucun aucun représentant de lmr alors
que on avait au gros son morceau de cent
mille personnes qui ont voté pour nous
donc c'est pas normal qu'ils soient pas
représentés alors évidemment
proportionnelle mais c'est pas logique
que des partis qui font effectivement
des scores sur des élections qui sont
implantés ne puisse pas siéger dans les
différentes assemblées pour représenter
les gens qui votent et qui qui les
défendent voilà vous souhaitez aussi
réformer les circonscriptions
législatives
alors les élections approchent
d'ailleurs quel est le problème
aujourd'hui si l'on met en fait les
circonscriptions sont pas beaucoup de
circonscriptions sont pas représentatifs
de la réalité les circonscriptions elles
sont faites sur le nombre et elles sont
pas faites les lecteurs voilà elles sont
pas faites sur sur la géographie entre
guillemets parle si vous prenez la 2e
circonscription de l'essonne c'est la
plus grande circonscription
quelque part il faudrait qu'elle soit
quasiment divisée en deux donc c'est
pour ça qu'on demande une réforme alors
il ya des partis politiques de droite
comme de gauche d'ailleurs qui sont pas
opposés à ça qu'ils sont assez
favorables mais malheureusement quand
quand ils sont au pouvoir ce soit un peu
une tambouille politique donc
voilà il n'en veut pas on veut qu'ils
aient une représentation démocratique
et enfin vous souhaitez stopper la
tendance du transfert des compétences
des mairies aux communautés
d'agglomération vous si je résume la
vision des les mères c'est vraiment une
la mairie là la base de l'état dans la
mairie où les jours la mairie doit être
le socle le socle de la vie politique en
france c'est la maison du citoyen c'est
celle où tout doit se discuter doit doit
la proximité une valeur que vous aimez
way we totalement parce que
évidemment si on compare une ville comme
je puis dire peut-être evry
courcouronnes
évidemment c'est pas le bon exemple mais
quand on est en zone rurale la mairie
c'est comme l'école quoi si c'est
vraiment le pilier central de la commune
c'est là où tout se fait tout se discute
là j'ai un copain qui est maire un
premier maire-adjoint d'une petite
commune dans le 28 là il est en mairie
tous les jours c'est du bénévolat mais
tout passe par la mairie quoi et alors
les agglomérations apporte beaucoup mais
il faut aussi un moment donné que ce
soit vraiment la mairie qui ce qui reste
décisionnaire de ce qui se passe chez
elle et non pas et je prends l'exemple
il faut pas que ce soit les autres qu
enfin mairie qui impose des choix ça
parce que si je prends mon
agglomérations qui le grand paris sud
et ben comme une commune représente une
voie
rien
et ont quelque part c'est pas normal
parce qu'il ya des prises de décisions
qui vont se faire au détriment des
petites communes par les très grosses
communes c'est normal je serai une
grosse commune je défendrai voilà donc
donc non il faut il faut je pense revoir
ça mais d'après ce que j'entends il ya
une réflexion aussi dans les
agglomérations à propos de ça justement
et pour finir cette émission la réalité
a perdu un influenceur de poids jean
pierre pernaut nous a quittés à l'âge de
71 ans il incarnait médiatiquement cette
france rurale qu'avez vous ressenti en
apprenant sa disparition ben un manque
une tristesse en nous on avait la chance
de connaître un petit peu il nous
défendent est sûre la chasse nous fonde
justement sur les éoliennes c'était
parmi ces combats il était vraiment
un porte parole en fête dans les médias
il met il la ville l'avait fait il le
faisait de manière naturelle en fait
parce que il était vraiment attachée à
ces valeurs que nous défendons et oui
oui on lui a rendu hommage je crois
qu'il dirige allons enfin moi en tout
cas j'y suis allé mais je crois qu'il
est dit plus haut si on n'était pas au
même endroit pour ses obsèques mais oui
un manque pas ce que parce que parce
qu'il ya peu de gens en fait qui ose
s'engager comme il l'a fait ces prises
de paroles ses coups de gueule à la
télévision c'était quand même oser quoi
donc donc on est un peu orphelin
aujourd'hui ouais merci beaucoup
viennois villardier d'avoir été avec lui
dans les deux politiques merci je
rappelle que vous êtes le président du
mouvement de la ruralité en ile de
france mais nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de l'hebdo politique à très bientôt et
bonne soirée et sur sensations
[Musique]
l'hebdo politique